- [Narrator] What's not to
love when it comes to lumpia,
crispy and flaky on the outside,
juicy and tender on the inside.
It's surely a party in every bite,
whether you enjoy this
popular Filipino finger food
as a snack or main course,
lumpia is a total crowd pleaser
at any family gathering.
So from our family to yours,
we're excited to share our
favorite way of making lumpia.
The word lumpia translates to spring roll
in several languages.
It's evolved for many Asian cultures,
so there's a variety of ways to make it.
Traditional fried lumpia usually
refers to shanghai lumpia
or lumpiang shanghai.
It's the most popular version.
We also think it's the
easiest one to make.
Lumpiang togue or sometimes
spelled toge or lumpiang gulay
is fried like lumpiang shanghai,
but the roll is bigger.
It's served with white vinegar
mixed with garlic,
onions, and black pepper.
The filling usually consists of vegetables
like julienne carrots, bean sprouts,
sauteed pork, shrimp, or both.
Fresh lumpia, also known as
lumpiang sariwa or lumpiang ubod
is not fried but wrapped
in something like a crepe.
This version is typically
filled with meat,
but can easily be vegetarian
or vegan like this one.
It's commonly served with peanut sauce
and topped with crushed peanuts.
Now, turon isn't considered a
version of lumpia by everyone.
We think this can pass for
a lumpia, but it's sweet.
A saba banana, which
closely resembles a plantain
is wrapped in a lumpia wrapper
with jackfruit and sugar,
then fried.
You probably guess which
version we're making today.
We're sticking with the
classic lumpiang shanghai.
When it comes to selecting a protein
for our lumpiang shanghai,
we tried pork, chicken, beef,
and even plant-based meat substitutes.
Some people add shrimp to the pork.
We love this combo, so if
you're into it, go for it.
Just make sure to coarsely
chopped the shrimp.
Today, we're going with ground pork.
Don't worry about cooking
your meat prior to wrapping.
If your meat is pre-cooked,
it will be harder to wrap
because it won't bind
with the other ingredients.
The meat will cook during frying.
The key to a good filling
are balanced flavors
and enough vegetables to keep
our protein moist and tender.
In our recipe, we're using carrots,
sweet onions, and water chestnuts.
Water chestnuts are
going to give our lumpia
a nice crunch and moisture.
You can chop these vegetables on your own,
or simply throw them in a
food processor and pulse.
Just don't puree them.
They should look like this.
Toss this in a bowl with our ground pork
and add some thinly sliced
green onions, garlic, soy sauce,
Knorr seasoning, sugar,
black pepper, and a large egg
that's been lightly beaten.
We recommend using a fork
to mix everything together
to avoid overmixing.
Overmixing our filling
can make the meat tough.
Then cover the bowl in plastic
wrap and pop it in the fridge
to chill for one hour.
Time to talk, wrappers.
You can make your own lumpia wrappers
if you have the time,
but store-bought lumpia wrappers
from your local Filipino
or Asian market are great
options and more convenience.
Lumpia wrappers are often referred to
as spring roll wrappers,
but don't confuse them with
fresh spring roll wrappers.
Fresh spring roll wrappers or rice paper
are thin like lumpia wrappers,
but they're clear and
typically not cooked.
We recommend using the standard,
traditional nine inch
round lumpia wrappers.
Be sure to pull all the wrappers apart
before you start rolling.
This will help speed up
the assembly process.
To keep your wrappers from drying out,
cover them with a slightly
damp towel or plastic wrap,
so they don't dry out.
If you don't do this,
the wrappers will fall
apart as you roll them.
The last thing we need
to do is make a slurry.
This acts as a glue and
keeps our lumpia intact
when it's fried.
Egg wash also works.
We did a test with just water,
but found that the wrappers unraveled.
To make the slurry, combine
a bit of flour with water.
And now, we're ready for the fun part.
Place a wrapper on a large work surface
and spooned five tablespoons
of the filling inside.
You might think the more
filling the better here,
but it's a delicate balance.
The wrapper and the
filling have to complement
and support each other
like a pie crust to its apple filling
and corn tortilla to its pibil.
Now, when it comes to rolling,
it's a lot like rolling
a cigar or a cigarette.
Fold the bottom half of the
wrapper on top of the filling
and push and tuck the top
half onto the filling.
Roll the filling forward away from you,
then apply the slurry onto
the top edge of the wrapper,
and then roll completely to seal.
And we did it.
It's that simple.
In most Filipino households,
you'll get an army of people
to help you with this part.
So recruit friends or family
when you're making these,
we promise they'll love it.
Once rolling is complete,
we would like to cut
them into smaller pieces.
We've found they are
easier to fry this way,
but you can definitely leave them long.
Either way, they'll taste great.
Now, a lot of families like to freeze them
to fry later for a party
or a quick dinner or snack.
To do this, set them on a
sheet tray in a single layer,
not touching and freeze for
about two to three hours.
Once frozen, transfer
them to a sealed container
and you can store them in the freezer
for three to four weeks max.
However, we want to eat them
now, so it's time to fry.
In a heavy bottom pot,
pour canola oil until
it reaches one inch high
and heat until it reaches
375 degrees Fahrenheit.
Once it's hot enough, gently
place some lumpia in the oil.
Don't overcrowd the pan.
You want to make sure they cook evenly.
Let them fry for about
five to seven minutes.
You know they are ready
when they look like this,
perfectly golden brown.
Set them on a cooling rack,
lined with paper towels
to absorb any excess oil.
Bring the oil back up to
375 degrees Fahrenheit
to ensure they get just as crispy.
Man, this smells like our
family birthday parties
when I was growing up.
We'll keep doing this until
all our lumpia is fried.
When it comes time to serve,
lumpia would not be complete
without a dipping sauce.
Lumpiang shanghai is often
paired with something
that is both sweet and
tangy, like banana ketchup,
sweet chili sauce, or
sweet and sour sauce,
so pick whatever is your favorite.
And it's time to dig in.
Grab one of those flaky rolls of goodness,
generously dip it in your sauce and enjoy.
We hope you give this recipe a try
and let us know in the comments
what your favorite kind of lumpia is.
To find this recipe and
many more, visit tasty.co.
Oh, yes!
(upbeat music)